nuclear-waste the worst type of garbage
for raccoons to get into now it's a
substance that we all know is dangerous
thanks to movies like this they
tormented him until he had a horrifying
accident and fell into a vat of nuclear
waste movin became the toxic avenger the
first superhero born out of nuclear
waste his face is so terrifying we can't
show to you now you'll have to see the
movie for yourself honestly you really
don't need to see the movie Co it really
isn't that terrifying this is it I mean
it's bad but if it's so ugly it's almost
cute again it's like it's like someone
melted a candle shaped like a pug
but the point here is nuclear waste the
radioactive and toxic byproducts from
making nuclear energy and weapons is a
serious health hazard and America has a
lot of it there are more than 71
thousand tons of nuclear waste stranded
at the nation's 104 reactors put all
those spent fuel rods together and you
get a pile as big as a football field
and more than 20 feet tall or you could
put them in a pile as big as two
football fields and ten feet tall or
half a football field and 40 feet tall
or 20 football fields one plus all the
point is we have a lot of different ways
and it's very fun to play with and look
that is just a waste from nuclear energy
we also have more than 100 million
gallons of hazardous liquid waste from
producing weapons and you may live
closer to nuclear waste than you think
one out of three Americans live within
50 miles of high-level nuclear waste
some of which like plutonium is lethally
dangerous and will be around for an
incredibly long time even microscopic
amounts of plutonium if ingested are
deadly one of the characteristics of it
it has an extremely long half-life
utonium 239 for example as a half-life
of about 24,000 years it's true 24,000
years and I just scratches the surface
it takes ten half-lives for plutonium to
become harmless so that's 240 thousand
views a unit of time
more commonly known as one english
patient and as any adult with an
American Girl doll collection eventually
finds out if you want to keep something
around for a disturbingly long time you
have got to find an appropriate place to
put it I cannot live with your murder
dolls anymore felicity stares at me
while I play she's dead
instead I'm clinking look I'm not the
first person to make this point look at
this news report from 1990 almost half a
century after nuclear power was
harnessed there still is no agreement on
where to store the waste we have built
the house said one critic and forgotten
the toilets a home with no toilets or as
they will to selling a Brooklyn loft is
calling it right now
artisanal composting wait you're
suggesting that I've in that botted
plant well you and I both know that I
will do that because this is convenient
to public transport and it has both
northern and eastern exposures it has
been 27 years since that clip and our
country still doesn't have a nuclear
toilet and that is our subject tonight
why do we not have a nuclear toilet and
it's actually easy to understand how we
got into this situation because during
World War two we rush to develop nuclear
weapons because we were trying to defeat
the Nazis who fun fact pretty much all
Americans agreed were bad at the time
anyway look the thing is we didn't
really have a plan for what to do with
all the radioactive byproducts that we
produce and this initially led us to
some mind-blowing ly stupid solutions
for instance for years we actually did
this they'd loaded the radioactive waste
and it was in barrels 55-gallon barrels
of radioactive waste with concrete
poured over it it's funny the ocean
don't glow out there outside a Red Bank
New Jersey really because we dumped a
lot of barrels out there that is true we
didn't just dump thousands of
radioactive waste in the ocean we did it
off the coast of New Jersey
that is so horrifying I'm surprised that
Jersey Shore was the title of a
light-hearted MTV series and not the
name of a harrowing documentary an
entire generation of children was born
without thumbs a phenomenon known to
locals as the situation and incidentally
not all of those barrels strength in
fact in 1957 when two barrels were
caught floating off the shore naval
aircraft were someone to strafe them
with machine-gun fire until they sank
that's right they shot barrels full of
nuclear waste with machine gun some
probably one of the most terrifying
interviews ever said out loud right
after Donald Trump is the president now
and wait wasn't Felicity on a different
shelf when we went to bed last night oh
my god
felicity is a waiting nightmare ha well
the truth is tossing barrel full of
nuclear waste into the ocean and
shooting them with machine guns is
actually preferable to at least one
genuine other idea that was thankfully
rejected and that was blasting it into
space a concept with a pretty clear
floor unfortunately we don't have a
great record with getting Rockets out to
the atmosphere if any one of them blew
up that would basically contaminate a
large portion of the earth with
radioactive material
so that's probably not a great idea yeah
you're right that's probably not a great
idea I mean a really great idea would be
also filling the Rockets up with
confetti so at least that way if there's
a horrific accident there's also a party
over the years we have dumped nuclear
waste all over the country and in many
places there have been frightening leaks
take the Savannah River Site in South
Carolina where waste from poorly stored
material leaked into the groundwater and
just watch this alarmingly laid-back man
explain the consequences of that there
are radioactive alligators on the site
radioactive materials are in the
sediments it's going to go up the food
chain and there's going to be
radioactive alligators radioactive
alligators they even have names try to
Gator and dioxin ater after two of the
wastes that poisoned them and that's
actually very clever because if I had to
give them names I don't know I'd
probably have gone with something like
oh holy a radioactive
alligator and oh no me there's
another one what nightmares God rules
and it's not just reptiles has been
impacted by nuclear waste researchers
are now studying an area in North st.
Louis County Missouri where tons of
waste from the Manhattan Project was
improperly stored some near a creek that
winds through residential communities
and people who live there have noticed
some alarming trends I got on Facebook
in order to reconnect with people from
high school
and we all immediately started noticing
but so many of us were sick least
discovered that the Department of
Veterans Affairs officially recognizes
around 21 cancers associated with
exposure to ionizing radiation and
compared that list to what we had we had
Oliver cancer every single one that is
an incredibly depressing thing to
discover on Facebook and it's hard to
know how to respond I mean you
definitely don't want to use the like
button because then it looks like you
really like the fact they just got
cancer now now though is that new sad
emoji which would really be perfect if
you hadn't already cheapened it by using
to respond to the news that Chris Pratt
and Anna Forrest was separating I mean
it is sad it is sad but it's not 21
cancer sad it's 9 cancer sad tops the
point is thankfully 60 years ago our
government and the scientific consensus
came up with a solution in 1957 the
National Academy of Sciences issued a
report urging the creation of a
permanent storage facility deep
underground basically a nuclear toilet
and while we did build a repository for
lower-level waste in New Mexico we still
haven't built one for the most dangerous
high level waste and as a result it
essentially been left wherever it was
made which is not good because those
facilities were not built with the idea
that they would be storing waste
indefinitely so to continue the toilet
metaphor we've basically been
in bags leaving them all over the house
and praying that they don't leak and the
most frightening example of this is the
Hanford Site in Washington State which
created two-thirds of the plutonium in
the u.s. arsenal and is currently
storing 56 million gallons of highly
toxic and radioactive waste underground
and over the years there have been so
many issues at Hanford that they've
achieved a dubious honor as one local
news station reported with an almost
prideful tone the most contaminated
place in the entire Western Hemisphere
isn't that a polluting factory or an old
chemical plant it's right here in
Washington State oh it's right here we
did it guys Washington State
home to the most contaminated place in
the Western Hemisphere thousands of
acres of apple orchard and several
attends my take on these grisliest
murders we did it right here there have
been a string of problems at Hanford
from explosions to toxic vapor releases
to over a million gallons of waste
leaking out of their tanks over the
years it has been so bad the government
has had to pay out nearly one-and-a-half
billion dollars in compensation to
thousands of workers but illnesses
stemming from exposure to radiation and
toxic chemicals they're a local news
station has done a series of reports on
Hanford and after a tunnel collapse this
may they found some of the
infrastructure there is almost comically
badly put together mistake during
construction are factors in the
dangerous state of the tunnels they're
55 and 60 years old well beyond their
expected lifespan in addition wood beams
holding up the tunnels are eroding and
what corrodes timber beams radiation
yeah you can't build something out of
wood and expect it to last forever he's
supposed to have learned that from the
second dumbest of the Three Little Pigs
Hanford hands-on is a gigantic problem
and and even though it hasn't produced
anything for 30 years the Department of
Energy still spends nearly two and a
half billion dollars a year on cleaning
it up which is close to ten percent of
its annual budget and it is pretty weird
to find out that a place you just heard
about is getting that much of the do E's
money it's like finding out that half
the Department of Agriculture budget
goes to this moose named Gordon I mean I
don't know the right amount but that
seems like a lot and in case you're
thinking well I'm definitely glad that I
don't live near Hanford remember there
are nuclear power plants storing waste
all over the country lots of it in
so-called spent fuel pools
that's where nuclear fuel rods are
supposed to be temporarily placed to
cool down and then put into dry
containers and then moved to permanent
underground storage sites but remember
we don't have one of those and in many
places those pools are just accumulating
more and more rods and what experts say
is highly unlikely if a Fukushima like
accident have
one of those the results could be
catastrophic the Northeast has a number
of nuclear power plants including the
Indian Point plant just outside of New
York City if any one of those were to
have a severe spent fuel pool accident
you're taking away a lot of big cities a
lot of farmlands a lot of the United
States for decades perhaps centuries
that's right lots of big cities New York
Hartford Boston and that last one is a
real shame because I as I understand it
they only just got under a sixth
yesterday so at least they could get to
enjoy their new life so so look it is
pretty clear we need to find a permanent
facility to store our most dangerous
waste and 30 years ago we actually
settled on a site Yucca Mountain in
Nevada Congress passed a law designating
it as our sole candidate for waste
storage now since then we've spent 15
billion dollars prepping the site as you
can see from this rather upbeat video
[Music]
located about 100 miles northwest of Las
Vegas Yucca Mountain is the most
thoroughly researched site of its kind
in the world
experts throughout the world agree that
the most feasible and safe method for
disposing of highly radioactive material
is to store them deep underground that's
right
the best place to put nuclear waste is
in a hole deep underground much like
Felicity wait what if she's not there
where is she mikage
so Yucca Mountain is our permanent
storage site so the problem is solved
right well no because well the site has
been deemed safe and the people in the
immediate area Nye County actually
support the project many Nevadans
elsewhere in the state really don't want
it and their former Senator Harry Reid
lobbied hard eventually managing to get
Yucca shut down now to be fair he did
have an alternative plan for all the
states sitting on their nuclear wakes
but to put it mildly it was not exactly
scientifically sound leave it on site
where it is leave it where it is and dry
cast storage containers if you're smart
what you would do yes sir
leave just leave it where it is if
you're smart what you would do is leave
the thing where it is is terrible advice
for dealing with nuclear waste although
it is coincidentally the title of
Britain's best-selling book on parenting
but but here here is the truth the
scientific consensus for decades has
been that leaving it where it is is a
really bad idea the shuttered power
plant at San Onofre in California is
storing nuclear waste and it's on a
fault line right next to the ocean and
that sounds like something you learn in
the first scene of a movie starring the
rock that you watch on a plane and look
maybe Yucca is the best place to store
our growing supply of radioactive
garbage maybe it's not I am NOT a
nuclear scientist I just have the face
of
and and our our new energy secretary
Rick Perry yes Rick Perry has said that
he is optimistic about fixing the whole
problem which does sound great although
he didn't exactly do a great job at
dealing with this disaster yeah that was
him on Dancing with the Stars and on the
basis of that managing volatile energy
is not really his forte but it's a thing
we've been saying that we are going to
fix this for decades now and we seem to
be no closer to a solution and let me
show you something that really drove
that back tongue to us because we've
been researching this story for a couple
of weeks now and just yesterday
afternoon we stumbled on a TV special
from 1977 the year that I was born
NBC News presents
[Music]
danger radioactive waste yeah this
problem is so old they reported on it
back when the news was kept in an
America shaped vault that you had to
open with a crank and as we watch that
yesterday we gradually and chillingly
realize that by pure coincidence
it hits every beat of the story that we
just told you it opens with footage of
sailors throwing barrels into the ocean
it looks at the facilities at Hanford it
talks about radiations impact on workers
and on families who live nearby and
while it doesn't have a radioactive
alligator
it does have radioactive cows which is
which is still good although I did
prefer our la alligator I liked it when
he went but the most chilling moment in
that documentary might be the one where
they sit down with someone in authority
and demand to know exactly when this
will be fixed when you ask when the
problem will be solved you get answers
like this what's the realistic timetable
realistic timetable is scheduled to have
a repository in operation by 1985 with
the selection of the sites by the end of
1978 for detailed work exactly nuclear
waste is a problem we were supposed to
have dealt with in the 1980s and still
cannot solve much like this Rubik's Cube
that I always carry with me you are my
John Valjean cube and one day I shall
defeat you and at the end of that
special remember 40 years ago
the correspondent delivers this special
message the waste increases every minute
the solution of where to put it is years
away and none of the previous solutions
has worked we are accustomed in this
country to act only in times of crisis
but with nuclear waste when the crisis
comes it will be too late and that was
from four decades ago we have already
waited way too long to resolve this
issue and we are dancing with trouble
here so if anyone says the government
can just continue to wait they are much
like a house with no toilet absolutely
full of
[Applause]